there is something magical about a great
hotel a sumptuous Lobby a cozy bed
perhaps a beautiful view but the real
magic in hotels today is technology
high-tech initiatives are completely
remaking the four to twelve billion
dollar industry 40% of hotel rooms are
empty at any given moment and that's a
problem that Expedia Priceline even
hotels tonight are addressing but Commun
hotel chief creative officer Scott
Williams from social media will draw in
return customers in his hotels
it's an emotional connection commune a
high-end boutique hotel group has become
a social media addict we're monitoring
81 channels so there's five social media
managers throughout the company and they
are assigned per brand and they manage
the flow of traffic so if they see a
customer tweeting I just got engaged at
the hotel of ital the hotel will send up
a celebratory bottle of champagne back
in the day of travel agents travelers
would stick with known quantities and
brand name hotels but with the rise of
internet booking the boutique hotel
business exploded big brands are now
just 53 percent of hotels but technology
in the hotel can still need a challenge
for the boutique's it's hard for
boutique companies to make that
investment in the technology and make
the bet on the right technology that's
going to be around in two or three years
that said technology driven change is
letting the best of hotels get back to
basics getting top dollar for the best
user experience